what is that one only
one him
alone
Prov all
thees Jesus Abraham Noah ISAC
is Allah
oh okay about so
like when you say like when you say
Allah is one is Allah's Oneness like
similar to our oness like like he's one
guy and I'm one guy you're
one so what kind of Oneness is Allah's
Oneness he's one he the
God creator the one that all the heavens
all the gy what does the one me in
the
he
singular like the Trinity God the Father
God the I don't really know about the
Trinity too much yeah yeah I don't
really know about truth yeah yeah not
too much have Che he like that one guy
is he or is he like one so so is one
person I'm a one person am I am I
one
Arab I understand that so so
like I don't think he's filming me I
don't I think all together like I came
by myself and they set the cameras up
he's ahead I'm ahead you're ahead and
Allah's
ah to say
this is
not you're inviting
us how is this not a sincere question I
don't get it
this
understand here to what the all the M
they
toship none but
Allah the Bible says that worship that
God if you're inviting us to
that if you're inviting us to that we
have like wouldn't you expect us to have
a question yes you can ask a question
but I mean I I just asked question about
Allah yes but you have the information
there so the information doesn't go I'm
pretty sure it wouldn't go into what
he's asking yeah I mean look you can
read it together if you want if you read
it yourself you read for yourself don't
read with him so you know the one
reading you don't read with him you
understand yes so concept of God this is
this is Zak sorry Dr Z I don't know if
that's how you pronounce your name yeah
but it says in
Christian it says you
know Islam is the only this has nothing
to do with neither maybe down here of
any use where is the con
Christianity and this is the section it
just seems to be like arguments against
Jesus
he not even saying this is what
Christianity is oh look this is the
definition of God look the concise
definition given in four vers he is
Allah the one and
only is difficult to translate it means
absolute existence and can be attributed
only to Allah but if it can only be
attributed to Allah then we don't know
what that
means look I just want to understand it
says this
as I say tell
you no I'm not I'm not Niger don't don't
use that word me
I'm n
don't you said BR to me
I me what
I
confused I don't understand how you're
how do how do you how do you give do and
then when people actually come with good
questions you don't I don't want this I
I don't want this
here
go I like we heard we heard the speaker
and attracted
us so can we say the same thing about
you that you're not
sincere you're only you're only it seems
like you're only here to talk to people
who are like completely ignorant of
everything but if we have inquiring
questions about what you give
us
even you just kept repeating the word
one over and over you never told me
Allah is one I'm one okay but I'm one
I'm also one one I'm one person one
human
being made you so Allah is the same as
me Allah no it's not is he the same kind
of one as him fruits such as they desire
so then a
is not a man who should not Li why you
go the Bible I don't it's your Bible
it's not Bible I didn't write it I just
we just want to the Quran says
thean is enough if you don't want to
believe
[Music]
it chrisan we're trying to understand
all of you Christian you comeing here
with a agenda or some the agenda is to
learn about this simple religion that
you guys say is clear it's concise it's
not as difficult as the Trinity but we
can't even understand what one is don't
understand you
keeping it's as simple as
this when you say when you say that
Allah when you say Allah's one am I one
like Allah
isoy for a singular yeah am I am I
singular like Allah is singular Allah
is I know that
but no so that's not answering the
question
that to you is is Allah singular the
waying
ismism is
upon to worship Allah what do you mean
by Oneness pism pism is when you join
partners with
Allah what do you mean by Allah does not
have a son he does have he does not be
so the people who so the people say that
Jesus is God the people who have no Sons
the people who have no daughters the
people who have no wives are they also
just like Allah you're not how is that
not sincere you who am I talking to we
ah
okay you keep you keep calling me BR no
but can go now because you you come here
you came here to ask about I given you
the stuff you got the information none
of that has the answers that we're
asking if you okay these people
supposing we're asking about brother we
asking about asking about asking
ask
about you know what's interesting though
right you know the basic concept of your
religion which I want to understand from
you is that Allah is one right now I'm
going to ask him if that's okay explain
it to you you didn't explain it he a
shake listen sh I understand please have
seat I'm let the stuffe
but the only thing
when sit down he can have cuz before you
guys came I went to somee you just got
to refresh that's all you 5 minute
respite cfee like I would say when you
guys say to anyone you know worship one
God I think it's fair for people to ask
what does one mean you know like when
you're you're one for example right
you're one man you're one man you're one
person I don't know your name what's
your
name you're one Abdullah you're the only
ABD right yeah so you're Ahad you're
one yeah okay we speak in English man
cuz we understand this concept in
English exactly I'm speak in English you
know there's not another abdah one I
don't have a twin yeah yeah exactly your
mind just grabs it instantly exactly
exactly so is that the same kind of
Oneness that you're talking about when
you say
Allah this is when we say Allah Allah
being one not Allah as in Allah being
one I understand Allah the
Creator so just like I I said to you
yeah yeah there's not another me even
though human being you human
collectively there's only one you though
yes only one me only cuz I didn't I
didn't B with that twin there's no so
you can just there's only one Allah
there's only oh so the way that you're
one you Allah is one that's that's
he's not
finished if you want to answer your own
question you can't do that sorry sorry I
didn't mean to come up that to you
instantly I'm just say to you I'm say
putting this way as maybe a child can
understand it in ABC mode yeah yeah yeah
I understand me like a kid
yes course I'm not say
that yeah I just want to make
for a
second yeah to you something we can we
can grab our
mind one yeah there's not two Allah
there's not three there's not three
Allah there only one only one Allah but
then the question next tension that
Oneness of Allah is unique in different
from from say there's only one me when
I'm a human being I well there's other
human other human beings there only one
but that Oneness is unique in a sense
yeah can I ask your question there's
nothing oh so it's like because like
Allah has something that no one else has
right Allah is like this and no one else
has that have no no compar way can
categorize put that way put so you can't
categorize or understand so you can even
though only one me but it can C it can
categorize me in the group of said the
human race okay okay Mak sense but like
there's no like Allah race there's only
one Allah but you can't say categorize
amongst the gods is there anything okay
you can't put Allah among God I
understand that is there anything that
Allah has that we don't have or we can
never
have you you would hear things on
linguistic uniformity okay because Allah
Allah send scripture to Messengers where
you walk in Earth so sent in language
that you utilize and understand and
communicate with each other so you hear
things on linguistic uniformity only on
that level but but but in
actuality it's no comparison best so
then there's no comparison between our
Oneness which we understand as one you
know anytime you use numbers in the
world I just tell you I just tell you
already yeah but I'm I'm trying to touch
on that concept if that's okay with you
but I don't I'll just give you from my
side I know I know I know I know I know
but I want what I want to do is I want
to see how it came together in your mind
you know cuz what you're talking you
didn't understand what I say I have a
bit of a problem and I want to explain
that so where is the problem when
I maybe you didn't understand what I
said no I understood what you said said
it's only one me I understand that but
you're also part
of my
answer there's only one me do you
disagree there's only one me I didn't
there's only one you there's only one
you only one Allah there's not two Allah
do you disagree with that one Allah
there's only one Allah okay you disagree
with there's only one Allah understand
so we're we're trying to we're try you
don't understand this I'm making very
clear to you there's only one Allah
there's not two nor three nor four Allah
you don't understand that if you
understand that then I'm saying to
you I don't know to move on if you don't
understand that let's see let's see why
he doesn't maybe I can explain so what
is the problem so here's the problem are
you to explain you to get the answer I I
want you to exp confusion if that's okay
yeah but I don't know what is to
understand like I'm said to you is only
listen carefully this is the
comprehensive of what I'm saying
statement there's only one Allah yeah we
talking there not there's not two not
three now for Allah do you disagree with
that got it yeah because those are
created things no like even when you say
1 2 3 4 these are created things in your
head I tell you Allah Allah send
scripture Revelation in language youu AR
using that language with the p Hebrew
letters you be no human using that
language okay but the problem that we so
Allah send a message into a language
that you don't know so he's
one he's one in a way that we can
understand so he's one in a way that we
can understand we we can understand his
Oneness it's not
Beyond about yourself into a scripture
into language of that human being let me
finish a human being you're utilizing so
obviously since human me utilize the
language you me understand the language
yeah so okay so good so then will you
answered in a way that that he I guess
had a limit to he couldn't get to this
between M difference this the didn't go
that far so but but it's good though cuz
we got we got somewhere so at least now
we know that Allah is one you give me
your feedback no yeah yeah I'm asking
you first but you have get no feedb for
me so before we can move on what is it
when I say Allah is one there's not two
right there not two right no three no
four no part nalization of one
Allah Allah is one there's no two you
don't believe Parts there's no two three
or four or five are more Allah do you
disagree with that it's not it's not
that I do you agree with or you disagree
with just one second I it's not that I
agree or disagree I understand what
you're saying okay cuz that's what
you're asking but I'm asking you do you
disagree that well I'm I'm not a Muslim
so I didn't ask you to be a Muslim I
know so you're asking me if I agree with
your theology you know numbers we I know
so I don't I don't believe particularly
in Allah but I do understand what you're
saying
God is one in the Bible is if you ask me
if I agree with that I agree with that I
agree with one second let me finish just
as is the Lord our God is one yes just
as using a language where you utilize it
yes it could have it could have also ex
God is not two three nor four would you
have disagree with him I would agree
with Jesus so the same I'm saying here
okay good okay
Goode with me let me tell you where I'm
at okay mentally so to but what I just
said to you I I agree that that when
Jesus says the Lord our God is one I
agree with what Jesus says I yes I can I
can understand what Jesus said so on I
just I just wait I got to say this now I
got I have to say I'm asking you I know
but you already you already asked me a
question was just speaking you just
speaking you already asked me a question
no you don't know what I'm going to ask
you but no you already asked me a
question speaking an alien language or
was speaking Lang I'm just going to go
and say this simple question it sounds
like Allah is one in a way that we can
understand
that's fine so it sounds like Allah is
one in a way that I'm also one is that
sh something that Allah has we have a
similarity with Allah I'm saying to you
you can't simple B stuff that any child
here would have understand but we
understand it we we understand it we
just don't agree with simple that's fine
simple no yeah it sounds
like the reason why theid only one
there's no two three because the kid is
literally comparing things in his head
with Allah that's why the kid can
understand thinking no that's how babies
think that to who man you're over
thinking too much okay I'm a girl I
don't care look look look I don't I
don't care if you want to we we have
something SAR for games like I'm not
here for this I'm not here you just call
me G I don't care look the point I'm
saying say overthinking like Sim I
didn't say I'm like a woman because I
over that's fine but I'm saying to you
why I'm this conversation
why yeah but it's not a conversation
it's one way respect peacefully why
aess
sh mentally to convers so so hey so what
we're you understand simple stuff I
don't think a kid would understand what
you're saying without simple simple what
we're walking away with is that we have
a similarity with Allah we have similar
we we're like Allah in
one just like just like you're one
Abdullah not two or three or four Allah
is one Allah not two or three or four
you I'll agree I AG I'll agree I agree I
age go so then you have we're like Allah
in that way there you go
no see that now I
can't Amnesia already have amnesia
amnesia yeah because before before
because before before I give you the the
difference between us our Oneness you
can categorize it amongst other things
like human race and I said this is and I
clearly explained to you before that you
guys forgot simple right now he forget
other creators I mean
Jesus I mean we give Mercy like Allah
gives I get what you're saying you're
saying you're saying there's nothing
like there's nothing like Allah angry
the way Allah gets angry there's so many
things I I tell I tell you respectfully
and I can't speak to you because you see
point that I already give you answer
far you said Mercy like us have mercy
but what I said to you I said only on
the linguistic uniformity you don't pay
no attention you school no he understood
everything you said I understand what do
I what what do I meant when I say only
linguistic uniform literally the terms
themselves are the same now
I that's what saying
mean I SP I'm because you want to talk
too much shut up and listen you but
you're the one talking the most l no
because because I were teaching because
you don't know nothing know what we know
listen what I'm saying listen what I'm
saying to you you don't want to even
hear you want to hear our concern we did
you got two years Len I'm
saying you got one mouth close it so
that we can hear no yeah repeat yourself
so you're like Allah and I'm like Allah
Allah is like youing very clear to you
not one not two you're not two not three
not four Allah is not two it's only on a
linguistic level oh linguistic formality
but you you don't understand what it
means okay I speak to you st Linguistics
what you own listic uniformity can you
tell us tell shut up for a second can
you tell us learn tell us tell us learn
go ahead tell us tell TR be human fail
your class tell us tell us actually got
a and b
as I don't know if that's you got I
thought you got and I got AAR you talk
too much we've been listening pretty
good and
listen again tell us tell us what
linguistic formality is listen so I
don't have to play a game I spell out to
you like ABC before Ain contradicted
Allah s ration to human
being you know what so the sh could talk
to us I'm talking to you and you talking
at the same time I tell you you waste of
time we're trying to find out if Allah
is one in the way that we are one but
for some reason we're confusing they're
try to find they're not sincere so went
from but you're only one person so
there's nobody like you and there's
nobody like Allah so like in that way
you're similar to Allah how Sim so look
there's no like there's nobody like
Allah right there what's your name
brother okay what you trying to what you
trying to bring we're trying to
understand okay we're trying to
understand what what what what does
Islam mean by you know Jesus no there's
only one only one Jesus only so when
there's only one Yousef there's only one
Allah
simar the same yeah we're similar to
Jesus
s say that
again so you're saying you're similar to
Jesus no no we're not we're not similar
in that way we have a we Sim we're not
similar in that
way can I explain
that no he can let him answer you just
asked a good question literally said
none of us are simar and I mentioned no
I never said that okay are you
Jesus we have a similarity
J what makes it similar to Jesus certain
things make us similar to Jesus and
certain things are not similar to Jesus
okay look so specifically for example
right Jesus is one person I am one
person I have a similarity to Jesus you
get that what's your similarity I just
told you describe it okay I am a
singular person Avery my name's Avery by
the way so look look let me tell you let
me let me tell you wait let me tell you
you I'm stupid so I'm trying to you're
not stupid bro no no I'm trying to like
you get it you're right I'm trying is
there another youf okay me and you are
similar we're similar in a way we got
two arms one head Allah has two arms two
eares and there are things that we don't
have Allah has two hands you're and I'm
I didn't ask you know this no no say
Allah me no no say Allah specifically oh
no Allah was clear not to us us Allah is
not a father right Allah isn't a father
okay he's not a father he our God is our
father Jesus God his
father
father me father so you understand
that you can you can be creator okay
let's say let's say I finish let's say
father you can create and you can be a
father being a Creator and being a
father not the
same I believe in one God that is the
father
okay okay do you see do you see but we
can agree on that yeah there's one God
then I have no argument with you well
you do you're about to find out why why
do I have an argument we're about to
show you one God we're about to tell you
how actually one father we even one
father but you don't believe one father
let me just say I'm going to say okay
one father
one because Allah says he's a father to
No
One father's not one of father is not
one of exactly but why do you say father
because that's how he revealed
himself God told us God told us to call
him Heavenly Father bro that's what we
so do do you do you determine what God
is or do we or does God I can say that's
a a language no but you
no you're not listening you you're not
listening does God reveal who he is or
do we reveal who God is who decides who
God Is Us or God okay so we're saying
that God himself listen listen we're
saying that God himself reveal that he
is the heavenly father okay to to to the
prophets and to the people but to to to
for Allah Allah is not a father no no
focus on the point Allah is not a father
that's why that's where we dis
you understand you understand that wait
before we go there do you understand
that that's our disagreement okay so
when we say when we're talking about God
you have a different concept of God than
we do okay all right and so but even
even in even in your uh religion you
have a similarity to Allah that you
don't acknowledge you don't you think
that you're completely other than Allah
but you're not no you're actually more
similar than you think for example you
can descend Allah can descend you can
put your foot in something Allah can put
his foot in something you can rise Allah
can rise as well there are
many like I said I'm very
stupid like like s myself down it's like
you know when you have when you give
birth say have you got children you
don't have children when you have you
got children no but let's say let's say
when youone of us have when okay when
you have you you have they see you as a
parent and they follow your
characteristics yeah so that's they have
Ace in you because they follow you and
they copy everything you do yeah and you
can say okay your children are a
representation of
you but is that what you're trying to
say no what we're trying to say because
you're saying let let answer you let me
finish well you did you as question okay
okay let me elaborate yeah you know what
take your
time it's TR to say that it's it's take
your
time cuz i
s okay elaboration it's like you're
saying something we can and everything
but you're making us like similar in
ways here but we're not no look I'm
saying that because we can't create what
he can exactly so now you found
something that's different that doesn't
mean there aren't things that are
similar I'll give you an example
right so now but now here's the kicker
right there is
nothing similar in your belief now in
our belief we believe that God has all
kinds of similarities with us you know
we exist God exists similar not the same
similar however in Islam you can't have
anything similar that's the problem so
even when you say Allah is one and
you're one and that's similar that can't
happen in Islam so that's why we're
saying we can get out of this because
our God told us how
you can't because your God told you to
shut up no offense so now when we ask
him stuff like what does Oneness mean
you can't compare any idea of Oneness or
any similarity in your head to Allah so
even when you say this is when you're
talking about Allah being unique no no
no no no no no no no
because not even not even I can see that
coming no no it's not inspiration I I
promise you I will not use inspiration
of the holy spirit for now okay I will
your you got to stay with me so when you
say understand when you say Allah is one
and you say oh he's
unique any idea of uniqueness in your
mind Allah can't be that so you scratch
that when you say
Allah go ahead go ahead goad you know
when you say any idea that you have yeah
how do you know what I feel
yeah you know the beauty saying I'm
saying me yeah I think that is an
inspiration
he gives you that knowledge yeah cuz
he's the owner of knowledge as well He
blesses you with knowledge and you come
up with that knowledge like straight up
divine revelation like the Holy Spirit
no no no no I'm saying if he blesses you
with that knowledge you're not saying I
did that you're still saying
alhamdulillah Allah gave me that
knowledge for me to say this that's what
that's what Islam says anything that I
do I'm saying for me anything that I do
it's Allah that's given something into
he's the one that gave me sounds a lot
like the Holy Spirit but I hear it
though that's what I saying but I'm not
going to use that though I'm not going
to use that I promise I was going to say
that it sounds like and then I said yeah
if you say that then it's free God then
you believe two God you know what I mean
but here's what we're going to say okay
now here's the kick up remember Allah
the the principle this is the rule play
this game with your friends M the game
is describe Allah without using
something created that's it that's all
you got to do describe Allah without
using something creative here's the
here's the question I want to ask you
are your thoughts Crea your thoughts in
your head are they creative well I can
say one thing yeah you know with my
thoughts there is a right
answer for me there's no right or wrong
answers because is right yeah because at
the end of the day when our our
thoughts we believe I believe that it's
called you know the devil he intres your
yeah sometimes yours are not your own
but they're still created right they're
not Eternal they're not uncreated
they're created well come into being
they come into no no if if you let it if
you live out your if you have a desire
no no no no I literally mean like I'm
going to get even more basic than that
like before you go even more basic right
look look when I think I'm going to go
to McDonald's